presumptive Democratic nominee Joe Biden
is apologizing for something he said
about African-Americans at a virtual
conference for Black and Hispanic
journalists Ed O'Keefe is covering
campaign 2020 Ed what did Biden
say well good morning Jeff the comments
came in an interview that lasted almost
an hour he was asked about immigration
and how he would engage with Cuba here's
some of what he had to
say what you all know but most people
don't know unlike the African-American
Community with notable ceptions the
Latino Community is an incredibly
diverse Community with incredibly
different attitudes about different
things you go to Florida you find a very
different attitude about immigration in
certain places than you do in you're
when you're in
Arizona late last night Biden clarified
the comment tweeting in no way did I
mean to suggest the African-American
Community is a monolith not by identity
not on issues not at all president Trump
had jumped all over the comments calling
them an insult to African-Americans and
in a separate attack during his visit to
Ohio the President also took aim at
Biden's Faith take away your guns
destroy your second amendment no
religion no anything hurt the Bible hurt
God he's against God he's against guns
he's against energy our kind of
energy Biden a devout Catholic responded
by calling the president's comments
shameful and said his faith has been a
Bedrock Foundation of his life the
former vice president's propensity for
gaffs is one of the reasons why the
president's been pushing for them to
debate a fourth time in early September
around the time that many Americans can
start voting early but the commission on
presidential debates has rejected that
request saying they would only offer up
a fourth debate if the president and
Biden agree to do so Biden and the
president now are scheduled to debate at
least three times beginning in late
September Jerica the debate over debates
continues sounds like it thank you edoki